six dollars and 38 cents
thank you so much congress thank you i
feel like i'm
a little popper congress may i have some
more
no you'll want some more a little more
little more than
and 38 cents per day please it's
actually going to be less than that
because obviously people aren't going to
get their checks
today who knows when they're going to
get their checks frankly
in my view the president should veto
this this is a ridiculous
ridiculous bill uh senator cruz just i
actually just saw this headline senator
cruz came out against it a lot of
conservatives are coming out against
this this thing is
a disgrace it's an absolute disgrace of
a bill it's not just conservative
republicans who are opposed to it
you've even got some democrats including
maybe our favorite democrat these days
tulsi gabbard who is having none of this
covid relief bill hey everybody
i just got back from having voted on the
house floor on this
massive spending bill i voted against it
and i wanted to tell you why
first of all this bill was over 5500
pages long
we received the text of this bill at
approximately
2 30 this afternoon and we're told we'd
have to go and vote on it
just a few hours later there is no way
that anybody in congress had the
opportunity or the time
to go through and read this bill to know
exactly what was in it
i've been here long enough to see how
provisions are snuck into these bills
in literally in the dark of night
without any announcement without
telling anyone what is in it and then
rushed through
in the manner that we have just seen
tonight
this is the height of your
responsibility and it is absolutely
no way for the people's
representatives to be able to represent
the interests
of the american people absolutely true
now what tulsi is focusing on here is
the procedural aspect the formal aspect
of this
how the bill was written how the bill
was sent over to congress how the
the representatives had no time to read
it before voting on it so
yeah procedurally that's pretty messed
up there's also substantive issues with
the bill
if you're going to have a relief bill
give people some money don't
don't give them and it really is not
everybody is going to get the money too
so it's actually
obviously it's going to be significantly
less than this
this uh amount it's not going out to
every single
american and it's just an excuse
basically the congress gives you know
a little pittance of money to the
american people and then they sneak in
all of their preposterous
largely preposterous plans there as well
tulsi has really impressed
a lot of us i think in the past six
months i was not one of those
republicans who was really on board for
tulsi
during the primary there were a handful
of of them who said oh you know she's
anti-war i really like kelsey
okay that's fine but she's broadened out
some of her political thought she's by
far i think the most
moderate democrat as a practical matter
on abortion
uh she's uh by the way not even just on
those sort of hot button issues
even on sort of slightly more esoteric
issues issues that don't really get a
lot of play
she's come out pretty strongly tulsi
gabbard is now coming out
actually against the federal bureaucracy
the deep state
the administrative state the
conservatives are always
crowing on about myself included tulsi
gabbard is going after those
unelected technocrats and implying that
in a free country a free people should
govern ourselves
heartless arrogant unelected cdc
bureaucrats have decided
that the lives of elderly americans just
don't
count now for months the cdc has been
telling us
that the elderly are the most vulnerable
but now they are recommending that a
hundred million so-called
essential workers which means healthy
people working at everything from liquor
stores
to telephone companies that they can get
the vaccine
before our grandparents can that members
of congress like me
we can get the vaccine before at-risk
seniors
can people like my aunt who is is
imprisoned in her own home because of
the danger that if she catches the
disease
she could die this is immoral and
bad health policy i had planned to take
the vaccine but
we'll now stand in solidarity with our
seniors by
not doing so until they can
i urge my colleagues in congress who are
under the age of 65 and healthy
to join me
i love it i love i'm still not going to
vote for tulsi gabbard because
she's obviously more liberal than i am
by a lot but i tell you what
if if the election were between tulsi
gabbard and joe biden it would be a
no-brainer
if the election were between tulsi
gabbard and the clintons it'd be a
no-brainer if the election were between
tulsi gabbard and aoc or bernie sanders
or whoever it'd be a no-brainer
she is saying sensible things and she is
thinking for herself
which raises this question i actually
had a journalist ask me this question
yesterday
if you know assuming joe biden does get
it the court won't come in and
save the day assuming all of that
will there be a new coalition that forms
a kind of political reordering so you've
got the
liberal establishment which is the biden
types
aided and abetted by the squishy
republicans you know all the lincoln
project or the romney
those guys do you think that that will
be one coalition
and that the woke left and the kind of
i don't know you could call it
red-pilled or based right could they
come together
and form a coalition to attack what has
been disparaged as the unit party you
know the
that the bush clinton that kind of thing
i don't think so i think that's fanciful
thinking i think tulsi gabbard is
totally the outlier here
she should be lauded for her efforts but
i i don't think that's going to happen
because
the thing about the liberal
establishment is they give the woke left
what they want
over time slowly the the progression of
the liberal establishment for the last
70 years
has been to the left it's never gone
back to the right it
is always more to the left some people
like the aoc types
are impatient they want this to go
faster but
just look at biden's perspective picks
they're very radical people
they're extraordinarily partisan people
they're not interested in unity and
healing which we'll find out later
you've got more prominent democrats and
democrat
helpers calling for republicans to die
like we were talking about yesterday
and you know you've got the occasional
person who's waking up out of this on
the left you know like tulsi gabbard
who's saying wait a second
these technocrats don't have the right
to form our political priorities
this is so far beyond the realm of
science or figuring out what works
you've now got these heartless
bureaucrats
at the cdc telling you that
your granny doesn't deserve the vaccine
because
they they find other people to be more
favored than
these elderly people i don't think
there's going to be any sort of
coalition here between the woke left and
the red-pilled right because
you know the woke left realizes where
their bread is buttered they realize the
liberal establishment is much easier to
work with
and much more likely to give them the
concessions that they want
in the long run you know there there is
a double standard here you'll see it
actually on public health
the way that skepticism of the virus and
the vaccine for that matter is talked
about
will vary depending on which group
you're in if you're in a favored group
you'll be talked
talked about with a great compassion
you'll be given a lot of leeway if
you're in a disfavored group if you're a
conservative you'll be mocked you'll be
castigated
you'll be coerced into violating your
conscience even
on even on a matter as private and
personal as
your medical life